I'm gonna be Sweden yeah even America
what the [ __ ] I don't know how to play
this America position I'm pleased
automatically do it do we do a [ __ ]
blow attack attack okay we play with
mines I guess we turn Oh
Sweden Sweden dangit Go Go Go Go Go Go
Go Go Go G again useless Sweden just
forget about getting there I'm never
gonna stop the ball
[ __ ] you Jolie goalie [ __ ] you sweet no
it's not scored yet are you kidding me
Sweden Sweden I keep singing the
Americans make sense
now we both practiced so we're both the
same team what I know thank you
I don't shield your goalie you [ __ ] oh
you sneaky little sniper oh no oh I love
this sound I'm here oh no a shilling you
damn it yeah yeah yeah Sweden go
shielded no [ __ ] don't you go to shield
your goalie how many times I
blow your [ __ ] up again I blew your
giant I blew my up dammit
now hi Sheila Tate now don't blow no yes
oh damn it sound of it yeah this is so
intense
go Sweden go you [ __ ] no that is a bold
pass the damn ball oh [ __ ]
what that's how we do it in Sweden
[ __ ] yeah Dulli sucks
oh my god yeah yeah but he's my goalie
doing
[ __ ]
oh no my goalie goalie goalie get back
go go go go go this game sucks a lot of
shields ah damn it
now your shield Fiona damn it
stop stop this nonsense go yes we did
what yeah are you [ __ ] kidding me
that's the dumbest [ __ ] I ever seen him
I know [ __ ] you and your football soccer
eyes no no one's getting near that ball
I don't care who you are that's [ __ ]
I have that I so had bad nut and shields
damn shields man that was intense
let's do again you going down now
[ __ ]
you what Cowboys
go whoa no come on goalies [ __ ] ah come
on
why do I blow my own guys up guys [ __ ]
please that is stop being blown up know
you're so [ __ ] lucky I hate you
what come on go who's laughing now fresh
game ever I got my goalkeeper I can't
chill him come on I can yes I don't need
to seem like oh this is this is this
gate and Sweden sweet thanks for
shooting my guy by the way
oh thanks for looking up your bow yeah
don't worry stay out [ __ ] sadness I get
it
stupid game just get Sweden Sweden
smacking donkey
oh my god you're some fake tits in
barbecue I'll be Norway this time so
they don't feel excluded all right
whoever wins this wins everything in
life everything in life yes come on
America now unite America South Africa
what are you doing out there you stupid
[ __ ] blonde [ __ ]
god I hate yes Josh get baked
Oh God go keep it what is my goalkeeper
doing out there whoa oh so dumb oh god
I'd blow my own guys up why do I blow my
bone [ __ ] up go go go go get it get
it get your skit you suck so much ass
man I don't know a goalkeeper watch my
goalkeeper
what are you doing goal key
to do this go go go go come on South
Africa South Africa oh no no oh are you
kidding me
now I seal in your ad Oh Dada Dada Jeb
Vlad oh no it's street trash forget
about it
oh god my goalkeeper oh no I keep
shielding your [ __ ] yes my they [ __ ]
man no keep it yes yes go again go again
go again
oh no my goalkeeper oh my god this is so
intense
come on South Africa [ __ ] yourself
Africa no no go go again goalie your
goalkeeper you suck so hard
oh sweet Norwegian no young man a valid
I'll it they've all i dilate the Mavi
name my name they've all i dilated so
good at this game i win everything in
life that means you just won Kim
Kardashian's booty mmm hey guys cry here
like this video if you enjoyed and suck
my ass brofist